♪ ♪
>> Tucker: A GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO THE
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT" ."
THE BATTLE OF THE CONGRESS AND
BORDER WALL IS STILL ONGOING AS
YOU KNOW NOW UNTIL ITS THIRD
WEEK.
LARGE SWATHES OF GOVERNMENT
REMAIN SHUT DOWN AND TRASH
REMAINS ON THE GROUND.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE WILL NOT
GIVE IN UNTIL HE GETS FUNDING
FOR THE BORDER WALL.
HE PLANS TO TRAVEL TO THE
MEXICAN BORDER TO MAKE HIS CASE.
THE BATTLE LINES REMAIN EXACTLY
IN PLACE AS THEY WERE LAST WEEK.
THEY CAN'T ALLOW A WALL TO BE
DEALT UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES,
BUT THEY SAY IT COULD BE BECAUSE
OF THE RISK TO THE SECURE BORDE
BORDER.
MALLS HAVE WORKED WELL FOR
THOUSANDS OF YEARS, SOMEHOW THEY
WON'T WORK NOW.
>> IF WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
BORDER SECURITY, THE
OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES OVERSTAYED VISAS.
THE SOLUTION TO THAT IS NOT A
CONCRETE WALL, THIS IS MORE >> T
CONCRETE WALL, THIS IS MORE >> A
WE DON'T THINK THE WALL IS A
GOOD TECHNOLOGY TO DO THE
OBJECTIVE.
>> Tucker: IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THE COORDINATED TALKING POINT,
JUST GUESSING.
BUT IN CASE IT DOESN'T WORK,
HERE'S ANOTHER IDEA.
>> THE INFERENCE THAT YOU DRAW
FROM THE WALL, IF THERE'S ANY
WAY TO DO THAT, IT'S ACTUALLY A
MORALITY.
TO BUILD WALLS IN PEOPLE'S MINDS
ABOUT WHO SHOULD COME HERE.
IT'S A VERY SAD THING.
>> I THINK IT'S IMMORAL AND
WASTEFUL.
>> HARBORED THE COUNTRY THAT
PUTS A WALL BETWEEN OURSELVES
AND AN ALLIED NATION?
THE WALL IS IN A MORAL SYMBOL
FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: JUST IN CASE YOU
ARE KEEPING TRACK AND YOUR
MORALITY CHART AT HOME, WALLS
ARE MORE THAN MORAL, IN FACT
LAUDABLE WHEN THEY ARE BUILT IN
JORDAN OR ISRAEL OR TUNISIA WITH
AMERICAN BANK IT LIKE BACKING.
WHEN THEY ARE BUILT HERE TO
PROTECT OUR OWN POPULATION, THEY
ARE IMMORAL.
THAT'S ARGUMENT NUMBER TWO.
HIS ARGUMENT NUMBER THREE,
ANYBODY WHO SUPPORTS THE WALL IS
INBRED.
>> THE IDEA OF A PHYSICAL WALL,
IF DONALD TRUMP LOVE SELLING
THIS TO HIS BASE, AND AGAIN,
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
SOPHISTICATED.
THEY ARE NOT BRIGHT.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
COMPLEXITY -- >> YES, HERE WE GO
AGAIN WITH CONDESCENDING TO
US -- >> IF THE SHOE FITS, YOU
HAVE TO WEAR IT.